okay today I'm going to talk to you
about acids and bases we're gonna see
what acids and bases actually are we're
gonna learn about the pH scale we're
gonna look at different indicators and
see what they tell us about different
substances so let's start off by looking
at this thing here which is called the
pH scale so the pH scale is a scale
which ranges from zero to 14 and
depending on where a substance is on
this scale tells us whether it's an acid
neutral or an alkaline so let's start
off by looking at acids so acids is
anything with a pH of less than 7 so all
of this section here of the pH scale are
all acids
now what acid actually is is it's a kind
of show of the concentration of H+ ions
hydrogen ions so the substance down here
let's say pH 1 will have an extra will
be a very strong acid something like
stomach acid or battery acid so this
means it has a very high concentration
of of hydrogen ions as we go closer to 7
we have a lower and lower concentration
of hydrogen ions so maybe here around 4
or 5 we actually it's still acidic
because it's still less than 7 but now
we have a weak acid instead when we get
to 7 pH 7 we describe these substances
as being neutral water is an example
pure water an example of a neutral
substance which means there's not a high
concentration of h+ ions and there's not
a high concentration of h minus ions
because let's have a look at the bases
so first of all I think it's important
there's two different phrases there are
two different key terms that we often
hear one is alkali and one is base so a
base is a substance which reacts with an
acid
to make salt and water that is the
definition there of a base all an alkali
is all an alkali is it's a base which is
soluble in water so they're similar but
please be aware of that subtle
difference now our bases or our alkalis
now anything with a pH above 7 so all of
these here are my alkalis now acids is
all about concentration of h+ ions
alkalis is all about concentration of Oh
H minus ions so it then behaves in a
really similar way that we saw from our
acids so right at this end we have a
very high concentration of our h minus
ions that means over here we have
extremely strong alkalis such as bleach
the closer we get to neutral the lower
and lower the concentration is of our H
minus ions so let's say around 9 or 8
here we have weak alkalis now the most
harmful substances to do with acids and
alkalis layer either end of the scale so
if I was to spill this on my hand a very
strong acid or a very strong alkali my
hand it could really damage me whereas
in the in the middle with neutral
substances that don't have a high
concentration of h+ ions or a high
concentration of our h minus ions
they're much safer to compare to our
strong acids or a strong alkalis so
what's this color scale all about so
there's different things called
indicators and what indicators do is
they change color to show us if a
substance is an acid neutral an alkaline
and the one that this scale is based on
here is an indicator called universal
indicator it's very useful because it
shows us if we added a few drops of
universal indicator to an unknown sub
it would change to one of these colors
to show the to show whether it was a
strong acid weak acid we'd be able to
find the pH based on the color change so
Universal indicator gives us a nice
change in spectrum of colors like this
there's also three other indicators that
we need to know about and what they look
like in each different condition so
first of all we have litmus in acidic
conditions it's red in neutral
conditions it's purple and in alkaline
conditions it is blue methyl Orange is a
different indicator against thee which
changes color to show us whether it's an
acid alcohol neutral in Civic conditions
that is also red in neutral conditions
and alkali conditions it's yellow now
the reason why the reason why I'm not
writing the word yellow and yellow is
just because it wouldn't show up for the
video now finally this really difficult
looking word phenolphthalein is another
indicator so phenolphthalein in acidic
conditions is colorless in neutral
conditions it's also colorless but in
alkaline conditions it have a color
change and it will appear pink so you
could use any of these different
indicators in order to determine whether
you have an acid or an alkali or a
neutral solution on your hands and
that's all we need to know about acids
and bases thank you